[Music]  what does finito man finito  it means little dream that's it no story  alright everybody sit down so that it's  a story on a block that was disappearing  and in Bach you'll hold Washington  Heights  the streets were made of music fame a  greatly exaggerated and these blocks you  can't walk two steps without bumping  into someone's very plan I was saving up  all my pennies in my piggy bank  this day this is gonna be an emotional  roller coaster the odds are against you  but there's a chance right a dream isn't  some sparkly diamond  there's no shortcuts sometimes it's  rough kicking out all the dreamers make  some noise  we had to assert our dignity in small  ways just listen little details that  tell the world we are not invisible  ignore anyone who doubts you  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]